oh snap
on vormir when she died we shed a tear
but it looks like the black widow solo
movie is finally
here oh bars would you believe i came up
with that
six to eight months ago wow dude and you
remembered it all this time
it's good freestyle yeah like the memory
stone yeah just the forgotten stone
all right guys looks like black widow is
finally here you know how it goes full
length watch alongs where you sync up
with the time code we'll be at our
patreon page this reaction highlights
can only show you
two minutes and they're the best two
minutes
we'll do a reaction we'll give our
review for it afterwards not our patreon
we offer a whole bunch of other stuff
same cheer you get reaction highlights
and watch log included would appreciate
if you guys can go ahead and hit that
like button it doesn't feel real i'm not
going to believe this is real until
we're done watching
and even then i'm still going to be
skeptical is this what they're really
putting out in theaters
[Laughter]
and also thank you to pratham jindal for
editing this video for us buddy or
depending on you know what time it is
maybe you quit and then you stuck me
here oh boy myself
thanks for editing this great you're
[Music]
where's the previously on previously on
the mcu
form here
[Music]
ethnically diverse group of kids this
does look like ohio
does this authentically looks like a
mountain
i would know families from there
foreshadowing their skills that's how
they defeat taskmaster
[Music]
brave girl your pain only makes you
stronger
theme stated
would you grab the ranch dressing for
dad
russians undercover as americans yeah
man
where's where's carrie russell oh yeah
who didn't see that joke coming a mile
away
whoa
whoa he's got a dahmer thing about him
that's his cover it's really effective
oh no everything okay
how long do we have i don't know like an
hour maybe
oh you remember when i told you that one
day we would have that big adventure
today's the day yay oh
all right let's go pack your pistols
i'm sorry oh does she know the
what's actually happening they are
packing they must yeah
be no leave it leave it leave it go wait
in the car
you have it yeah it's the only copy the
only one not on fire
[Laughter]
oh boy okay
he's coming he's coming baby's coming
[Laughter]
[Music]
nicely done did not see that coming at
all didn't see that coming
chilled yeah
he's gonna grab the tail isn't he
[Music]
oh my goodness yes
wow
listen wow those are great practical
stunts in this stand
damn
nice
wow this is awesome
[Music]
what a fun family adventure dad did
promise an adventure
[Music]
how disgusting
[Laughter]
we've been reduced to this
usually don't watch americans flee to
cuba
who are really russians
mommy you know it makes you stronger
remember
the theme of the movie
the red guardian returns ray
ray windstone
secondary theme and the north institute
how is molina she's strong
you need to hand me that gun
i want to go back there stay in ohio
oh
come here holy crap david harbor dh
i think i'm just now noticing this maybe
or or some real nice beauty makeup
you're gonna take care of each other
okay
and everything everything's getting
better
oh
this is where we get a cool origin story
in the form of a montage yeah
my favorite
this is the fir is this the first cover
in a
marvel movie it feels like it yeah
outside of
you know the pop songs and guardians but
yeah this is my first cover
[Music]
it's wanda's programming yeah yeah
it's all in the hex natasha
you gotta say i appreciate this opening
credits montage
a lot of cool historical fiction
happening here yeah
ray winston saw a lot of popular
political figures
the board supremacy
the timeline is clear now it all makes
sense
don't do this do what come after me
you're embarrassing yourself it looks
[Music]
desperate
[Laughter]
got an empty nest secretary ross you're
tracker sir
oh i didn't realize how much i miss her
she made this target deployed smoke
she's on foot with the package say hi
i'm going to the ground
ooh rooftop chases let's see that
mcu tom cruise run
never buy the rooftop chase
alleyways and bizarre chase that's all
right
oh wow oh
the stunts in this movie hit me yeah
it's got a lot of punch
oh
[Music]
yeah oh i did it the other
oh
mysterious nipple chills dude she took
the red pill
gross it's like universal soldier
oh yeah it'll be fun to count the action
movie homages
smile
all righty steve rogers on natasha
romanov
for three foot or four we need to make
it very clear what timeline we're in
has to not confuse the audience
you're in my bed did you get everything
on my list got passports
entry visas mix and match you should be
able to stretch it to 20 or so
identities
fanny long bottom
that is a legitimate name
that is obscene in the uk what's all
this junk
oh just some mail and personals from the
budapest safe house
budapest yeah
no it's it's budapest through the pest
budapest is a real place but i only get
excited about it when it's brought up in
a marvel movie
yeah that's why they established the
nation to make that cooler
or the dead city in hungary right
stop the movie and google geography i
know geography
why did you break
so the female avengers love watching
movies and shows
they all grew up getting socialized to
my movies and shows
[Laughter]
day one
[Laughter]
damn
he's got some imposing ass footsteps
yeah
he's wearing really heavy shoes you
should know i'm a better
shot than i'm pissed off
[Music]
oh whoa that little wobble in it too
really sells it
yo we got black widow fighting
taskmaster
oh she did her move yeah
get your wrong moves just doing this
[Laughter]
copy
this taskmaster not have a personality
at all
not yet
oh man
you gotta say the action's been really
damn good so far yeah
well captured and just punchy
choreography
i forget what the name of that effect is
called when you blend like
cgi go into real human but yeah
it's done really well
[ __ ] we go in a budapest
budapest
so we're gonna talk like grown-ups
is that what we are put it down before i
make you
you put yours down watch your steps
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
i'm gonna call it cops
with white flags wrapped around our
necks just like in ohio killing drakov
was the final step in my defection to
shield
and you checked the body confirmed the
kill
there was no body left to check there's
always
ew that dude there's so much action in
this room i know
they're always surprising which is good
it creates the feeling of being on the
run
[Music]
there's definitely some paul green grass
in here
[Music]
top-notch music man
[Music]
yeah rooftop chase yeah
see they had to make you want it that
much more
[Music]
oh man she is a persistent ass woman oh
[Music]
oh wow
wow god
okay she's fine and then she breaks both
of her fingers
[Laughter]
ow
oh
messed up that's so messed up oh
whoa god and that that broken leg
[Laughter]
gnarly
the bomb in your head always gets me
that is a messed up leg that should be
the thumbnail image
isn't this gross with a big red arrow
pointing to it
i hope that's the post-credits scene
it's gonna be a lot of self-terminated
black widows all across the city
yeah there's going to be a trail of them
leading this fast master
oh [ __ ] he's back
this this dude ain't subtle at all
he doesn't have a single f to give
oh
oh my god so much
so
the avengers towers yeah like if the
c-1000 was every avenger
they're gonna bump into arthur fleck in
a second yeah
still got some things to learn you
didn't say one word about draykov's
daughter
you killed her i had to i needed her to
lead me to drink off
we need confirmation drink-offs in the
building
no way
and here you are not so sure
i need it out wow
why do you guys do that thing like the
there's
this thing that you do
because pain and suffering is every day
and we are both still a trained killer
except i'm not the one that's on the
cover of a magazine i'm not the killer
that little girls call their hero
ouch wow they're still going to suck
black widow toys right oh absolutely
absolutely
by the end they'll make her completely
morally fine
morally justifiable in every way
takes more every day children who don't
have anyone to protect them
just like us when we were small maybe
one in 20 survives the training becomes
a widow the rest he kills
hmm where are you gonna go i don't know
i don't really have anywhere to go back
to so i guess
anywhere it was more like an invitation
i'm putting together into the red room
and killed rekov even though the red
room is impossible to find and break off
is too slippery to kill
yeah that sounds like a shitload of work
[Laughter]
[Music]
see in line there's so much cutting in
this scene
even the emotional bonding is action
dude flores she's amazing yeah she holds
that accent real well
[Music]
guards there's something in here can you
guys check this out for me
to the door on the south wall
[Music]
they get all prettied up to go into
action yeah you gotta get those poses
[Music]
i guess he was just waiting for the
right opportunity to do that
oh jeez
you made a scene didn't you
go to the upper level surprise no one's
going for their helicopter i know
no
do the superhero pose
[Laughter]
flip the hair
[Music]
this feels like a level out of a bond
game
what are you doing are you kidding me
yes you are absolutely
she's the best part of this movie
i think for good reason probably
we're
[Laughter]
you didn't think this through did you
haven't you seen a
this would movie a cool way to die
oh she's awesome oh she's a little
insane that's good
well he just murdered a whole bunch of
prisoners
it's okay they're prisoners there's no
value to their lives
oh you can't hear me huh
she worked directly for director far
more than i ever are you telling me that
molina
is working for the red room present day
she works remotely outside saint
peterson
i don't think we have enough fuel for
some petersburg no
we're good we'll make okay
[Laughter]
i did my best to make sure you would
succeed to achieve your fullest
potential and everything worked out
nothing worked out
we accomplished our mission in ohio
elena you went on to become the greatest
child
assassin the world has ever no one can
match your efficiency your
ruthlessness oh thanks
dad are we there yet you'll know when
we're there
i i
ah yeah yeah there are pigs in the
montage
they're the key to everything yeah
oh no
this movie's got an interesting pace
to say the least
reserve more thoughts for later
it still fits
i never washed it once come and drink i
never washed it once
oh god come in
did that pig just open the door yes
it did good boy alexi
[Laughter]
you don't see the resemblance
he didn't look like that 20 years ago
but our family was never real
so there's nothing to hold on to we
played
our rules to perfection who cares that
wasn't real
what that wasn't real oh
please don't say that it was real it was
real to me you are my mother
you were my real mother the best part of
my life was
fake
you got out draco made sure no one could
escape
are you gonna say anything florence pew
gosh what can't she florence do
you're not even the first mother that
abandoned me no you weren't abandoned
you were selected by a program that
assessed the genetic potential in
infants
awesome i believe a bargain
was struck your family paid off but your
mother
she never stopped looking for you she
was like you in that way she was
relentless what happened to her jacob
had her killed
huh oh man it's like when you take
method acting too far
[Laughter]
i'm sorry i already alerted the red room
and i'll be here any minute
please tell me that's taskmaster it's
got it
has to be done i don't know they're all
just helicopters masks to come in
like a jumbo jet
forward
there's your boy it's the boy there's my
boy
i've been waiting for him isn't the guy
who was helping them with tickets the
one who said
he was playing black widow i mean a
taskmaster
yeah i feel like and then they've like
not put any information out about his
character at all
yeah i'm sorry
oh you're not you're not sorry
damn richard why does he look good in
that
let's not keep him waiting taskmaster's
one of the pigs
what that this that was a joke worth
repeating
we're touching down in one minute now
you'll know how draco stayed above the
radar all these years
i was literally above the radar
oh i'm surprised the avengers
helicarrier never bumped into surprise
yet nothing has found this
mysterious hovering compound
that was cool
[Laughter]
it's the first time i've seen a title
card over a floating location
that's cool
i wish taskmaster had some of his
personality
cut the brain out identify the weakness
oh this is a much less cool way to die
[Laughter]
alexi
very nice cells i know right
what about romanov she turned her back
on the people
on her blood she had nothing i gave her
home
when you look into the eyes of a child
you have raised
no mask in the world can hide that
[Music]
neat reveal cool
that was cool well not to the mission in
paths
how did you do that i designed these
cells myself
mission impulse what family what
what it's me it's mama you have a two
inch blade concealed in your beltline
what
what what are you going to do to me
oh ah they have explained why she is
awake
so once we're inside i'll activate my
tracker and russell come running
you are aware that you are still a
global fugitive yes ah
problem only have uh one earpiece set
i'll give it to you thank god we got
that flashback
explained no plot holes
here
you feel anything when i killed your
daughter is this your
wanted past maybe his daughter's the
task master
oh
weird oh how strange
really i guess i guess
or maybe not but but up yep there you go
oh no
nearly killed my antonio
i had to put a chip in the back of the
neck
look at her you find it difficult
yeah yeah freaking weird man expression
on her face
geez she's a perfect
mimic and she fights just like all of
you
oh is that olga curlienko can she hear
me
what is going on there you want to tell
her
you're sorry well you should have
thought of that
before you blew her face off that is
twisted not to work i have rats in the
basement though
that was a mistake do it
no oh no
safe deal
are you controlling me i'm not
controlling you natasha
but there is a pheromonal rock smelling
my pheromone
oh gross oh
so messed up
we're horrifically intimate
soldiers widows taskmaster
the odds are stacked together she did it
let's see how easy it is you'll have
your own soon enough
there are 50 people on this planet oh
stop it
don't tell me just stop
i don't tell you when to stop and how
will you know when to shut up
ouchie god damn it you're weak
but it's easier to be tough in front of
defenseless little girls
ouch i could do this
all day these girls were trash yeah
thrown out into the street i recycle the
trash
oh man there's so many wait there's like
how many are looking at here i couldn't
tell it seemed like the whole wallet
faces all over it so
my widows can start and end the wars
they can make and break things
interesting
i can finally come out of the shadows
using the only natural resource that the
world has too much of maybe she can't
smell the pheromones right now yes just
break your nose
yeah even if you locate the database
i'm getting to show you the key how you
won't be able to take it from him
as long as we can smell him we won't be
able to hurt him
i'll just hold my breath not enough this
is basic science natasha to block
receptors and
well back to her center you have to
sever the nerve told you
i can handle that you weren't quite
strong enough
so i'll have to finish it myself oh
she's gonna do that
[Laughter]
so is she gonna lose her sense of smell
now time it just right
oh okay ah i thought she was gonna time
joe
you don't mind but she's gonna jump
through the plane
well i know it's like changing plan i
completely demolished one of the engines
and we are going into a controlled crash
[Laughter]
some really interesting entity choices
in this room
yeah i like to throw you into stuff
take hard left turns
took my childhood you took my choices
and tried to break me but you're never
going to do that to anybody ever again
no oh black widow versus the black
widows
ouch whoa
man her nose is going to be permanently
damaged
she did all of infinity war with no
sense of smell
[Music]
don't talk about fight club
cool good timing
the reality stone
i have to go back
that's why natasha couldn't smell thanos
stop i hate to know stuff but one of the
dudes owners from my deviated sept
yeah just you know guys
task masters trapped you know you got
free taskmaster too
[Music]
eject
because i'm free
free fall from 30
000 feet
go my sisters
[Music]
wow star look at the avengers a day
hopefully this gets more viewers
do you see the girls no
i hope no one's below the than the
ground sokovia is just down it's
always just right there
just reopening the city
yeah they're just gonna do their job no
matter what these soldiers have free
will and they
love they love their jobs cool
oh good for you red guardian
let her out antonia
sorry for blowing you up
you got you got one of those gas things
come try to kill me
[Music]
oh she's on the week this was fun
cool way to die
where'd it go you later not bad
glasses
get her do it do you get your arms back
you'll fall faster
yeah control your everything learn that
oh damn look at you natasha
[Music]
huh you're getting really lucky to hear
elena oh yeah
yeah point break
[Laughter]
there goes taskmaster doing her tasks
i just watched you do that and now i can
do it
wow
wow let's go
master the task of not being my enemy
she she used the move to take off the
helmet
i suspect no one's going to have issues
with how they change tasks absolutely no
one
not at all i'm sorry
i'm sorry he's gone i'll go go verify
that
yeah go find the nobody left to be found
is
it was real to me too
i finally felt some
at the most important time in the movie
yeah
yeah we fight with you i'll hold them
off
[Laughter]
if it can work out with the four of us
you know there may be some hope for the
avengers
okay well if you're leaving then i guess
you should take this
no you can't not your fist
ah
oh my god all the ethnically diverse
widows are here
us women got to stick together except
for bad man
and dumb men
[Laughter]
and all the you know dude grunt soldiers
[Music]
yeah were in the next adventure
dealing with bureaucracy
two weeks later okay
[Music]
she got her haircut
ah okay
where are you gonna go it's funny my
whole life i didn't think i had any
family
turns out i got two one of them is a bit
of a mess right now i'm gonna go
break a few of them out of prison
[Music]
tasha never thought she had family but
she did
all through infinity war i'm like
where'd they get this
during the battle with thanos where'd
they get that [ __ ]
bioluminescence
interesting that was an experience
indeed pretty sure there's a post credit
scene at least one
i'm still expecting a joke post where
they do return that bmw
well that was okay
it's a black widow adventure i really
wanted to love them
i didn't love it but
there's it's not without its pros that's
for sure
i'm not just saying that's be kind there
are things i genuinely really liked in
it
love florence pew yes really well done
action
some i think great isolated scenes
yeah when it really commits to having
scenes and lets itself breathe for a
little while then you reach
yeah like a shot or two and you know
certain scenes
yeah like in the family dinner scene
i was like damn they keep oh whoa they
stopped cutting what's going on here
they got out of action mode they forgot
to tell the editor yeah
and uh there's some really funny moments
some very funny moments some marvel
humor moments
it's uh it definitely could have been
it it was it was the the pacing was off
and the uh
what it wanted to do a story about i
don't think it really quite
knew i feel like there
some there's something off about what
they wanted to do a story about
it was like there's the black widow
origins we're not gonna do the black
widow origins what if you did a movie
that was like an adventure she had the
dealt that is tied to her origins in
some way yeah it's about dismantling the
tools of her own oppression
but but that's not really but that's how
in the action but yeah like the subtext
it wants to get to i feel like yeah it
doesn't it
is more like seasoning than it is
the foundation i really think that it's
i kind of get the impression that it's a
directing editing problem mainly editing
problem i think it's a directing editing
problem
i found myself observing this movie at
certain points
instead of being in it going i feel like
these scenes if they were just
edited differently might work better
because and it's not just the fast
cutting it's the
it's the like i didn't quite know what
mood it wanted to be or what
emotion it wanted to evoke it was kind
of moving at a weird pace
the transitions between flavors yeah
could be a little jarring
i mean when they're i i felt like it did
the best
at that when it was attacking you with
an action scene but when it was shifting
out of action into
character it it did not have like
as much grace as you would hope to sell
those things oh it's not
it's not the smoothest it's not the
smoothest movie
no it is kind of cacophonous in a lot of
ways it is like riding around in a
banged up helicopter
and yeah i am curious about whether
people will be
appreciative of what they do with tasks
they're gonna [ __ ] hate that what are
you kidding me
yeah even i'm here going like in the
moment i was like oh what a
weird twist and then halfway through i
was like
not even doing anything
yeah it's like yeah i feel like that's
that you could apply that to a lot of
these movies like there's a lot of cool
stuff
and you're just like take it one step
further no it's a decent outline
yeah yeah yeah yeah and it mostly gets
all the plot beats together but it could
have used maybe
another pass on yeah character
breathability and
real impactful subtext
or you know yeah really hitting its
themes in a way that is
uh uh what's the word evocative i don't
know i'm a little disappointed
i i had fun though with it like when i
was watching it i was having fun
it's fun to react to and um
the action scenes are exciting and all
the performers are good you got great
performers here
i thought red guardian was a little
wasted too you know like they're just
yeah there's just a lot yeah like it
seemed like there was so much you wanted
to do and it didn't have a good
grip on its pacing and tone that it
i i i wasn't i didn't feel much other
than
fun when it wanted to be fun and
and uh yeah in terms of like the
dramatic heartstrings
barely felt it that was the thing and i
got to be honest about that i barely
felt the dramatic heartstrings stuff
yeah i thought they had a lot of good
setups in that about you know how we all
felt about our family shared experience
together and it has
good moments tailored to that but
at the same time part way through it
started to become
sort of clear to me that that's not what
we're here to explore you know and so
that
in some ways like it's cool in the
layout of the editing to show like we
need to mislead you with molina
and the masks and all that stuff and yet
there's something about that that i feel
like we could have gotten with the
characters to really
sell everyone getting on board with
natasha
or something because they have one
dinner
and then the red room gets there and
it's gets go time to the finale so i
mean
it's strange like i was under the
impression this director might have
i feel like in another situation it
would be i really wanted to focus on the
storytelling
and but i had to i had to do more action
than i wanted to
and then when i watched this movie i'm
like i kind of get the impression that
this director of their specialty was
more
action and not really the actual
storytelling going on
because because so much of what wasn't
working would sometimes be
enjoyable or passable
due to just great performers you know
like florence pew
like she's so natural owns every scene
and i
i felt the most for her there's
something kind of really jarring about
red guardian here the shift in
before you see him okay let's go just
shut up
i think i know what's gonna happen
[Music]
seinfeld was a good show
[Laughter]
oh this is the carry ending
[Laughter]
you're not supposed to be bothering me
on my holiday time valentina
oh bothering you oh no no i'm just here
paying my respects i've got your next
target
maybe you'd like a shot at the man
responsible for your sister's death
cool cool
oh buddy no
and that's why she's in hawkeye
absolutely there you go
right two people we like against each
other marvel does best is getting you
excited about the future
it doesn't matter what movie we just
watch because the promise of excitement
to come
oh man damn dude
she's going to hang out with wire that's
a good post credit scene that that was a
good post credit scene
yeah yeah you gotta get props for props
or do though
i'm gonna be hanging with wyatt russell
yeah yeah yeah
sometime all right let's talk about it
and you know further upset the people
who don't let you criticize a marvel
movie
even though i've clearly loved the
majority of them we're not gonna get
paid for this review if you keep talking
all right guys look i know how this
video is going to go how this review is
going to go all right
i'm going to say like things i liked and
i'm going to get really bogged down with
my criticisms
john's going to say a few more positive
things to me for the most part be like
yeah you know you're right and then by
the time it ends it's gonna
by the time this review is over john's
gonna be like i think i liked it a
little more than you
but you know yeah review done
man i know exactly what's going to
happen yeah yeah
i'm not standing in your way
you're the true task master oh gosh uh
okay fine i know
this is not a conventional review
because we're putting at the end of a
reaction
but i i okay task master um
i thought taskmaster was it was a cool
idea of what to do with them and in
terms
of pulling a little uh rug out
underneath you there's like
random things that the mcu does with
switching things up
from mandarin to uh boner
you know like things like that that was
one of the more interesting ones for
sure
i mean that sincerely because to have it
be the daughter
uh it has a personal effect towards
natasha which is neat and it makes it
more disturbing for who's underneath the
mask and it elevates the ray windstone
character
in fact i'm saying it's so much to the
point where a big part of me actually
really likes the idea
i'm not married to taskmaster it was it
was so odd to me when i was watching the
movie because i'm like where's this
guy's personality
like yeah his taskmaster has a
personality he's staying like
you know evil [ __ ] and stuff so yeah but
in terms of what taskmaster
is in this film there's a big part of it
doesn't appreciate how
it was mainly used as a device
and i didn't feel much for it because of
the
the way the movie was paced and i even
think for the character of
the even if you're just using taskmaster
for like cool powers and abilities
i didn't really find that to be fully
met either
uh i thought they could have done so
much more
with that it seemed like they kind of
wasted a lot and then to
have taskmaster end in a way where
is now you're free to be
uh just a a regular human being
i don't really care man i kind of want
some taskmaster too you know and and
i don't really feel much for this plot
well and the other thing too the
shocking
moment when it happens it's like what
the hell that's sadistic
yeah but uh as it
and i i really was thinking i was
already formulating the review in my
head as we were watching
i was thinking to myself that's a good
sign yeah
i was thinking to myself that i was like
it's clunky in the first
hour or so and uh but the last half hour
like when she was a ray winstone
um no right that's right one there's ray
stephenson and ray winston
yes okay we're both in king arthur so
that gets confused but yes yeah ray ray
wins
yeah that scene i was like okay maybe
maybe it's like i'm gonna love this
movie in the last half
yeah and then i didn't and uh so yeah
that was that was that
so yeah i just didn't think it missed
the bench
i just didn't feel for anything that was
the thing i didn't feel much
well yeah that's the tricky part is and
you know especially with taskmaster it's
it's a
setup that is something that yeah you
could use
to great character effect and i feel
like we only got
the a couple conclusion moments of like
here's natasha's
extending the you know branch of
compassion that she has developed
and uh you know that's kind of it and
then you know she gets to be freed
that's cool but yeah it also feels like
taskmaster is just one of
many opposing threats in this movie
often gets lost among other widows and
other
presences at hand so yeah and with the
more emotional side of the story i mean
that's an example of something that yet
does
have roots to it that you could expand
into an interesting idea you could
change the character but in a meaningful
way
uh but i agree that it is just a device
and i often felt like
it's like i liked a lot of the themes
concepts and ideas they were going for a
lot of the settings they were showing
but often craving a real sort of
emotional resonance underneath a lot of
them because it's like all the setups
are there
and all the you know themes are stated
but i was
wishing for a layer deeper of like real
resolve
with you know their family element like
it's i'm
gonna use a little less action i think a
little bit
a little less action a little more
storytelling yeah
or maybe i don't know proportioning
those things a bit differently because
you know like
in the first part of the movie i
remember you said like wow there's so
much action
and then in the middle not that the
movie ever really like slows down
but you know it starts to be like when
they're on the farm okay i'm like oh
yeah
this is a scene that's kind of going on
for a while so this almost feels like
the intermission of the movie
uh and then we're gonna go into the
crazy big finale but so much of the
plotting and the stakes feel so rapid
to the point that yes some of the impact
is very surface level or is very sort of
it doesn't linger
too long yeah that's what i mean is like
it's it's a weird thing to criticize
because i'm like
i can tell you what red guardian's arc
is here you know like i can't it's
it's here it's it's a character who was
a dad
or under the disguise he was selfish
everything he did
is selfish he's a very narcissistic
personality
and he doesn't consider others emotions
like he he constantly thought about it
and in the end he
really realized what his shortcomings
were and what he really
that he really did love and even though
a lot of that love was
from uh a a a selfish place for how it
made him feel it just fed that
more motion he wanted to give back and
be more nurturing and giving
and do the right thing which he doesn't
really get any a chance to
do that he says stuff but he's gonna
show it
you know yeah and i think they i really
think
the movie really fails to hit the mark
with him too as a character
and i i thought that his tr
like everyone else made sense but red
guardian
didn't like when when you see molina
who she is as a mother and then where
she is 21 years later it's like yes
there's a lot of fill in the blank and a
lot of it's things we didn't see
happen with her but her portrayal and
the with the writing and the performance
that rachel weiss gives
that i could see the transgression and
it made a lot of sense
elena same thing even from a little girl
to a grown-up
adult actress you could feel the inner
child within her you could feel that
child who was like
i really you were my family and i missed
that and i'm
traumatized as [ __ ] everything and i
didn't want this life so i repressed
everything with my sarcasm you know and
i kind of i
have this like hollow point of view
towards life but i love you guys and i
actually feel you know she
she has like these subtle nuances and
then when it comes to red guardian
he's like this really caring
compassionate father in the beginning
and then he'll [ __ ]
this is wildly different and i don't
really get
how he went from that other than the
text
of this of what they're telling me of he
really
[ __ ] sucked the d of ray winstone and
wanted to rise up so i guess through
there he already changed into this guy
you know and uh yeah it's like he had
these glory days of the past
and uh but you know it's like i don't
really
that's the thing they're telling me
history but yet i'm not really feeling
the history imbued in this movie and
a lot of this comes down to some just
feeling that's that's the issue is all
feeling and the movie just didn't make
me like i said i could tell you stuff
because the movie's
saying it yeah but i'm not feeling it
you know yeah well that was one of my
favorite ideas that they brought up with
this was the whole idea of how everyone
felt about
their formed family and how at least
from the kids perspective
even if natasha denies it that's a lot
more affection oriented and from the
parents perspective there's a lot more
distance
and i felt at least as of this first
viewing it felt like at times there were
inconsistencies in just how the
characters were choosing to remember
that because
at times it was like alexi being like oh
yeah this job i
didn't care about this that whole time
was agony and then a couple scenes later
to be like but i loved you kids
yeah i'm like it didn't feel like two
sides of the same coin it just felt like
two different feelings in two separate
scenes
or something that didn't quite ring as
an overall
truth and that again kind of kept me
from fully connecting to that as much as
i was like rooting for it
they always have me rooting for stuff
but i feel like the moments i felt and
connected with
the most were the times when natasha and
elena were hanging out together like
you know the the few times where it's
not even that much about action
and they're just in between moments i
think too you know what is
even a lot of those intimate moments are
shot like really close up
so like there's a i don't know it
creates this different level of like
pertinence to what's going on whereas if
those scenes that may be visually
breathed a little more
perhaps but the editing stood out to me
i thought this was
terribly edited unless there was action
it was weird i was like the actions
edited great even the ones where you're
where it's a little bit more crazy with
its camera work because it's like it
starts off a little bit more
[ __ ] in your face and some of those
action scenes remain that way
but then there's other action scenes
that are more fluid with the way it shot
like the first fight between taskmaster
and black widow
that's a really fluidly captured action
scene i think
uh but then when they when it came to
the scene when they're when they're just
like drinking beer and talking while
she's stitching up
elena that's when i was like damn this
editing is not
not good this is like this is i kept
thinking of that that
that means taking three shot oh with all
the cameras
i'm like damn why there's so many cuts
in this one dialogue scene
yeah there's a lot of adr throughout the
movie too that's what i mean i was like
this is
what is happening it's choppy uh it it
it doesn't flow
well it's all there like it's all there
like i think rachel weiss does a really
great job i think she's a wonderful
performer i think
weirdly i'm like i think david harbor
does a great job too
absolutely he's so like he's he's so
uh what's the word i'm looking
boisterous
exactly the word i was going to say yeah
yeah i know absolutely
he's so boisterous and i was i wasn't
thinking
ever david harbor is putting on a
russian accent and doing this i believed
him as this guy
even as much as i thought the choice
and the transgression from one guy to
the next is
jarring yeah you know yeah like i i
would have helped i think if even the
girls were like what the hell happened
to you you know yeah
there's a real confrontation if that
character really has to confront himself
i think take like fat thor yeah they're
all like what the hell
you know yeah having that with him
because i'm like there was a very clear
image you painted of this guy
at the beginning of the movie yeah and
it's he's so different
and the fact that the women are not
having any type of reaction like you
guys are acting like this is what he was
like
yeah yeah yeah where all you get is a
little bit of like oh you got fat and
we're moving on
no this guy's way different yeah and i
thought again
like those would have been nice
opportunities to
like you said it's all in the text it
technically all happens
but i feel like even so much of red
guardians moments
in the movie like he doesn't get to my
recollection like a particularly heroic
or badass moment
he kind of just has this emotional arc
to have
which isn't that plugged into the core
of the movie and yeah most of the time
he's just a punch line he's
he's there for comedy he's comic
reliance he's a terrible he's a
punchline
and like i wish they could have written
a line with that and also
i mean like i really loved rachel vice
and i thought like that whole thing with
the pig they brought up
was kind of funky because at first i was
like oh this is dark man okay they're
introducing a nasty shade of this
character that you know
should be reconciled at some point but
then pretty much after that she seems to
just develop
a whole lot more compassion i think this
movie pussied out on how dark it could
have been
i agree like winter soldier was years
ago and that feels darker
yeah yeah absolutely and more per way
personal
and uh and and i mean what do you think
about uh scarlett johansson
i thought she was good yeah i thought
she was great i thought she was good too
and i thought this
you know for her if this is her send-off
from the mcu i mean i thought her
performance was good i've heard
some early responses say that she feels
like a supporting character in her
own movie i i because florence pew is so
good
i can see where that comes from to me it
felt like you know she's still kind of
at the core of everything but the thing
that hampered it for her for me was that
somehow even though this is a really
personal mission for her it all ties
into her
family life her origin story the few
things about her life that are the most
messed up and the most
close to normal and yet it's
the same point it doesn't really pay off
or seem like it really
wants to dig into that stuff and so it
kind of just feels like another
adventure that natasha was on
you know why we know we know from
filling in the blanks
of [ __ ] like age of ultron of when you
like what happened with her
it's weird to go like the way they had
like the humorous scene about ripping
out the
ovaries and all that stuff and it's like
i like that it was
uh elena doing the delivery on that
because it wasn't like they're making a
joke out of it
because the whole idea was to say like
no you screwed up our lives
yeah yeah absolutely oh you don't want
to hear about it yeah
try being us here's exactly why it
doesn't work with black widow uh
natasha specifically they don't spend
any time with we know
we fill in the i hate that i hate that
we have to
like it falls on the movie to revisit
truly the emotional core of
why she has this goal to take down the
red room
we know the goal we know what she has to
do
but we don't ruminate or or or spend any
time
truly with just a [ __ ] scene
of just her truly dealing with
like like let's we have to feel why
think of like any good revenge movie
yeah it's like a tale of vengeance uh
any revenge movie you have to feel
why they're getting revenge yeah you
know it's not just oh they did some
messed up things i got to kill them
and that's how it it's kind of how it
feels like her
but elena no for her that's what it
feels like
yeah yeah and but yeah because you're
meeting elena through this
movie and you're more in her you're more
in her shoes in
certain ways because even you know re
she's re-meeting natasha after so long
but yeah
it it it funny enough feels like it
could have been
any evil organization that she was in
the right position to go
and take down not necessarily the one
that made her and scarred her and that
she had to run away from
yeah we needed to see the emotional
effect that it has
of her learning that the red room still
exists
and they did nothing with that instead
it was just
oh well [ __ ] bang another reaction
that's that's how every action scene is
right it's kind of like aquaman just
[ __ ] reactions he just exploded well
that was
no i'm just it it bothers me it it
really bothers me
no it's uh yeah yeah and and weirdly i
thought that was one of the more
lucid at least early on aspects of the
movie because you know you're on the run
people are attacking you like that puts
you off guard and on edge but one thing
i'm sitting here
realizing is again with the pace at
which the plot accelerates
i i wish we could have also just like
lived in the
i have to be completely off the grid on
my own like you know you see her
camper out there in the you know
wilderness and i'm like oh cool like
maybe for a minute between
the flashback of family and the you know
rest of the adventure we'll see kind of
what a rough
life this is for her to live uh but it
really just kind of it it seems like a
lot of stuff isn't as
big of a struggle as i feel like it
ought to be given the fact that she has
no avengers resources
no team to call upon except this cobbled
together
family who is all at odds right now and
two she doesn't seem to try to hide
herself when she's out in public
and when i'm like aren't you like all
hats aren't you like a worldwide
fugitive yeah yeah it it it feels like
it could have lived more inside of that
stuff and it also feels like as funny as
like as much as we've seen pit bits of
black widow's
origin and as much as this isn't an
origin story i feel like going
back like we see the origin of her
family tie
and i almost feel like between that and
the rest of the movie maybe should have
been a
secondary prologue where it is sort of
re-acquainting you
to the young life inside like as much as
i like that opening montage
i feel like that could have been the
scene and then really help to
re-establish
why this red like we know the red room
what it does why that's bad why they
should be vanquished
but it's it yeah it relies on you
knowing that instead of actually putting
it in the text of this
movie yes it's not just about having the
the knowledge there's like logic and
emotion you have to let us
feel like really connect the emotional
context
not just be like oh yeah that was messed
up to her
so it's strange you know i feel like
i feel like scarlett johansson this is
her best performance as black widow yet
she shines less than a lot of the other
performers
even even ones that aren't being used as
well as she is
it's a strange yeah it's strange she's
the least interesting
one in her own solo movie and this is
her best performance she's ever
given yeah i would i would confidently
say that
this is coming from a guy who clearly
isn't a big fan of this movie
and and yet everyone else was just more
interesting
yeah and it's not just because they're
new and they just they just are they
they
seem like they care more about writing
them and uh
weirdly this is the kind of movie that i
see and i'm like
if this if i didn't know that this was
just you know a send-off movie i would
be like you know they set up some good
stuff and i'd be interested to see how
it grows in the sequel
yeah but yeah so what happened with ross
he showed up
i love that he even made it into the
trailer and he's not
he doesn't do anything in this movie no
he doesn't do jack he
she literally is just he shows up he
shows up twice
he's in a couple close-ups and it was
interesting the way he does
nothing he yeah literally does nothing i
uh after that
big black uh you know cut to black at
the end i was like okay are we gonna
is she gonna be like with him or talking
to him or is there gonna be some
machination or deal or anything
yeah yeah and i don't know i mean i i'd
have to go you know first viewing but i
feel like that is
a symptom that affects a lot of the
other things is like even though there
are certain things that do feel very
high stakes and of great consequence
there's also a good amount of things
that feel pretty easy
and feel without consequence and that
was one of them
this movie spent so much time reminding
me of the avengers and how there's
like so much bigger things going on yeah
it's been so much time that i was like
damn you know like a joke or something
here or there or maybe dealing
with something with natasha of like why
are you here
you know like you're an avenger do you
even need to be a part of this
and like dealing with her true motives
for being here instead of constantly
like yeah you make your jokes about the
avengers and stuff
it just made all the like they kept
talking about it that it made this feel
smaller mm-hmm and i'm like this should
have felt like the really cool
personal you know yeah this should have
been huge and vindicated
bringing mission over and this should
have been very cathartic
yeah i'm like yeah i don't really feel
like there's any real peril here like
it's
cool some of this like like the action
is cool and the stunt work
is phenom like everything you guys saw
in the reaction on the technical side of
like the music is wonderful
yeah the act like literally the action
was super impressive to me
i thought they did a fantastic job with
the action
and would i have liked a better finale
showdown with the action yeah
but i thought the the sky sequence was
pretty spectacular but again
it it loses the personal to you know
we're in a big thing falling out of the
sky
yeah you know and then even uh uh uh
the fight with all the widows was like
lackluster that should have
been like the raid it should have been
that should have been that should have
the epic
or atomic blonde that should have been
the epic fight scene
where she's trying not to kill them you
know
yeah yeah when they're trying
like she has to keep fighting them and
defending herself and taking them down
but she can't that would have been a
cool
i don't know they could have had a
better set piece with if she had like
the vials mm-hmm
and then she has to like reject them one
at a time or something like that yeah
yeah
yeah or i don't know it's not really
stupid because then they just team up
with her
but okay but that's another problem with
the movie i didn't give a [ __ ] about
that
like i'm like i care because i know it's
messed up you know like
i know it's messed up what they're going
through but this moment of just like
she freed the widows i'm like has this
there's
so much happening in here that my heart
doesn't have enough time to get attached
to anything
yeah and to you know that's a moment
where the editing benefits it in the
moment because
you see elena strap the grenade with the
serums and you're like cool that's going
to come back oh look all the widows are
in one room
it's going to happen here and there yeah
this is where it happens it seems like
that
should have been a moment that was
executed with a certain amount of
unexpected cleverness not just
oh damn it's already in the room yeah
you know it seems like it should have
taken
a certain amount of ingenuity and maybe
even
sacrifice or just like those moments in
a movie like this where the main
characters
past their limit and is just you know
this is the final stand basically
they've kind of accepted that this is
the end
and somehow prevails but there's i don't
know especially toward the end
it feels like she's pretty well in
control like especially with everything
with ray windstone
and i don't know like if certain aspects
have been handled differently maybe i
wouldn't feel this but two i mean like
he just dies in a
helicopter explosion yeah exactly
ultimately
some of the stuff about them being a
family at the end felt
a little forced to me too it just didn't
feel like it could breathe in
in a natural environment so it sort of
seemed to just like need to happen in a
certain order of the scrutiny
yes felt perfunctory yeah it's a movie
i i think it has a lot of shortcomings
and i want you know me guys like i want
to be nice
but at the same time i gotta be honest
like that that movie did not
really i was i left more instead of hate
i don't hate the movie
because there's a lot of things about
that work and even when it's like flawed
i'm like ah but it could be worse
it's so great hey like it's it's
literally okay it's a pretty decent
marvel movie
i expect more i i don't i i think they
should have done
better i i can't just give it a pass
it's not an introduction movie
no yeah this is supposedly her send-off
movie her swan song
movie we've wanted a long time for this
character to have her own standalone
movie
and to me the disappointment of
how it does how it's just okay and how
it's it's flaws or it's just so like
in my [ __ ] face that i i can't
uh i i gotta be on it like it really
kind of annoys me
that it i'm like what this movement
pushed back like a gazillion times
didn't have time to fix some of this
or expand it a little bit like this yeah
and for yeah for a send-off movie for
someone who's been
a core part of the unit like you know
from
iron man 2 onward we've had natasha and
so
i feel like they could have this is like
a two hour and fifteen minute movie
right
i would have accepted a bit longer just
given
what we're here to do and yeah i don't
need as many [ __ ] actions
yeah and i told her stories yeah yeah
and the fact that this is long overdue
this was an avenger who did the one who
didn't aside from hawkeye i guess who
didn't get their solo intro movie who's
a
a big huge part of this and it does feel
i've i
had this thought part way through i was
like if this hadn't come
after game and it didn't have the whole
mantle it's supposed to carry of sending
off you know uh
scarlett johansson's natasha and all
that stuff you know if this was a phase
one movie i'd be like yeah it's pretty
fun it's pretty pretty decent you know i
had a good time like there's
there's nothing that like overly upset
me if i'm thinking about it
that way but when i think about it as
what it
seems like it's intended to do i do feel
like
they could have been a more complete and
a more cathartic
and a more emotionally rousing send off
rather than like damn that was a pretty
cool mission
glad you freed the black widows
yeah ot fagbenly was good as
as a mislead for advertising who showed
up in two scenes
to be not a love interest kind of
i know exactly what a certain part of
the internet's gonna say though
about woke [ __ ] making taskmaster this
is woke thing
women stick together the man is dumb or
the other man's evil
the other guy is friends friends without
the guy
all the women are together at the end
i'm like i know exactly what this pocket
of the internet
it's gonna be freaking saying and it's
gonna just annoy me
i don't view movies in that light of
like oh god you're pushing my woke
agendas [ __ ]
but uh it in the end when the widows and
they're picking up taskmaster
my mind just started going oh god i hear
all the comments already
and the fact that i felt nothing towards
it mad me concerned that other people
that i'm like okay if i don't feel
anything towards this moment
it's just gonna piss off oh that pocket
of the internet so much more
yeah it was more akin to what i felt
when i watched what was that meryl
streep tom hanks with the post
yeah at the end of the post when she's
like walking out and it's got that like
gorgeous lighting and everyone's just
like her looking at her like
this woman look at what this woman did
yeah like i love that movie in that
moment i'm just like
too much i love that and that's kind of
how i felt here
where i didn't even think about it until
that moment
when they were all uh yeah when they're
they're all like they get out
and then they pick up taskmaster and
they're all holding hands
that's when i was like oh i see it all
now hey you know
i see the guys stick together i mean i i
didn't i don't think it's there the
whole
i don't i didn't see it at all even
looking back i don't see it
until that very moment you know part of
it makes me wish that some of that play
because they did a lot of that play of
like
i'm gonna try and get through to you
emotionally and it made me wish that
sometimes
that would actually maybe have worked
because it just never worked i thought
they did a really nice
job writing a lot of the female lead
characters like
they were great yeah and the performers
are my favorite part
yeah yeah yeah and i would argue that
in those female lead performer
characters and and what they get as
dialogue and themes and whatnot it's not
sitting here going just girl power girl
power all the time
no oh god no it's not it's not any of
what captain martial
yeah it's not dogged down by any of that
in a weird way not that this the movie
needs it but you know if taskmaster had
just been taskmaster as we know him from
the comics i almost wondered if they
could have done some kind of
we'll wake this guy up too we'll let
this guy you know be
be free as well because he's part of the
same system of oppression that we've
been under
or something and it's like for making
such a big change to that character it
it
feels like it almost amounts to less
because then it's just like
she's got this messed up history with
natasha you still saw kids toys now
because she's getting murdered right
that's right she didn't she didn't
murder she only
thought she thought she were the kids so
you still sell toys
yeah and that's the only person she
thought she murdered look guys you know
i
freaking love marvel like majority you
guys know that people think
i clap for everything just dealt with a
comment like that yesterday
and uh this yeah you just tune into the
ones that we clap for
yeah man oh well all right guys
black widow what did you guys think what
i am very much excited for is
the future of elena i am extremely
excited
she was a pitch perfect performance and
man the trailers do not capture at all
just how great
it's like i just assume she'd be really
good because it's florence pew
but i was like oh man i did not think i
would love this character as much as i
do
she is so rich in her like
everything about her performance was so
damn
good the thing that i walked away most
from
was [ __ ] you know like sucks say about a
black widow but
damn am i excited for the future of
elena i'm very
excited about the future 100 in fact
there was a bit of like a send-off
moment and
when they're looking upon the rubble and
they got the shot of her that shot that
was in like a lot of the trailer thumb
hills
her on the left and her on the other one
on the right and looking up where she's
like you should be the one to free them
that's when they look upon the
helicopters landing of the widows yeah
and it's like that's to me the passage
of the baton moment yeah absolutely
all right well
i'm not saying sorry [ __ ] it you gotta
agree what's my opinion
sorry not sorry i'm sorry guys
if you want to take it up with me i'll
apologize to everyone in it
leave your thoughts down below yeah
subscribe if you want
hit that like button if you want
marvel shills out marvel chills out
go for it john adelia chamberlain
if there's anyone at our patreon
who could kick an ass and take down an
evil organization not only with
kicking ass ass hickory you know what
i'm trying to say
i'm articulate today just like you
adelia because you would be able to
incinerate
any foe in your path with a well chosen
word a tongue lashing a turn of phrase
adelia i would hate to get into a debate
with you because i feel like you would
decimate me
and uh you know if what the hell are you
talking i'm just trying to
edify adelia's intellect and her
badassness
i mean she's been more and more in the
spotlight no matter how nervous
it seems to make you you seem to power
through it
working with the schmoes it's it's good
stuff man you're you're
well on your way to becoming an
international assassin
the world is crumbling around me and i'm
just trying to connect this to the movie
because for whatever reason that's
always my instincts but also i just want
to share with you
this weird conception of how i think you
that you could become an international
super spy
this is probably the best shoutout we've
done
there's no wii in this one i have done
i have done the best i tried anything
shout out to
possible and well that was
great a piece of hot gold
check your shoes i think we just stepped
in hit
i'm sorry i'm not sorry not sorry sean
doesn't know how to be sincere
listen to dealing
sincerely grave and
gravely serious
i don't know i admire you adelia you
seem like someone who's really come out
of your shell lately
like you're feigning it stop it